for years Bangladesh's economy has been
one of the fastest growing in the world
but with patchy recovery after the
pandemic and warnings of global
recession it's struggling the government
is seeking 4.5 billion dollars loan from
international monetary fund and
political parties are unable to agree on
how to hold election due December this
year
there are largely two crises the nation
is going through one is the political
deadlock the bigger parties BNP and our
mili could not agree to a credible
election mechanism and secondly the
economic crisis which covers all kind of
things price hike energy
bills are going out of control middle
classes is a struggling
people angry at the government's failure
to stop soaring energy and food prices
around on the streets demonstrating and
many of them are not members of
political parties
these protests are bound to happen
people with fixed incomes are struggling
house rent energy cost and all food
essential prices are rising to almost
double now but people's salaries are not
Rising
this government has done some
development work like Building Bridges
and infrastructure but not much else
really food essential items and rent are
at an all-time I'm high low-income
people are facing a lot of hardship
public anger is also growing over what
many says as excessive spending on
ambitious development projects and their
acquisition of corruption and cronyism
Rights group accused the government of
increasing attacks and intimidation
against opposition members
at this protest rally I was harassed and
slapped by the police they told me that
if I wanted to stay in this country I
would have to support the ruling party
of the awami league otherwise I should
leave
the economy is struggling for that
energy price have increased partly a
knock-on effect of Russia's war in
Ukraine opposition parties have
channeled public anger against the
rising cost of living and to protest
against the government
Bangladesh leaders clearly have a lot to
deal with and many here expect they'll
be adding more protests and unrest to
their list in the coming weeks Chandra
Chaudhry Al Jazeera Dhaka